a person who has a million dollars for
the most he's as close to broke as you
can be your daughters would you want
them to be happy no I want them to be
productive the only thing worse than
investing in a house is giving money to
the bank and letting them have it people
are being told a bunch of Lies buy a
house and one day you're going to be
fine invest in IR you're going to be
fine and they said I'm going to be fine
if I just do these things but we know
that most Americans are living paycheck
to paycheck the US dollar is likely to
fail people know it yet they save it get
a [__] t-shirt I am broke and on the
back and I am hustling
Grant Cardone this is crazy so 2016 me
would absolutely be losing it right now
to be in a room doing an interview with
you yeah well my pleasure thanks for
having me here appreciate it thank you
yeah do you remember Alex and Lea hosi
yeah of course yeah I saw him the last
time I saw him actually I was swimming
where were we were we in Cabo on a boat
yeah we were on Cabo on a boat uh
Sabrina and I were on little ski
and we pull up to this boat and Alex and
his wife were on the back of the boat
and they realized it's me in the water
so it was a freak wow justo or France
yeah Cabo That's crazy cuz Ila was
telling me that she got Alex a gift for
Christmas and she was saying he's such a
difficult person to get a gift for
because he could buy anything he wants
he has everything so she's like what
does exactly so she said it was 5 hours
with you and I think she said she paid
like 50,000 an hour no no it was for you
to cons paid 100 25 or something and it
wasn't 5 hours it was maybe 40 minutes
120 grand for 40 minutes is that like
your going rate for that it goes to our
foundation so it's not it's not you know
it's a good cause but it's it's not he
wanted to tap into what I was doing and
understand hey what are you doing that
works and and it paid off for him I mean
I think that was two years ago three
years ago gosh yeah so what does that
work out to be a minute that is that's
that's where his mind goes immediately
what it is you need is one one minute to
change your life I mean really you need
one idea one and he's the kind of guy
both of them those guys are they'll take
something and turn it into into
something you know to gold and they did
so what do you notice about the type of
person who's going to pay1 something
thousand for an hour how do they come
prepared for something like that do they
ask you have questions yeah that's good
number one you know somebody that pays
that much is either a huge
Fanboy right and a bit weird or they
very very serious in the case those guys
very serious you know committed to their
career looking for some hacks and did
they come with questions I think they
did you know we send people like a list
of questions that they could consider
you know to get them ready some people
actually say that I don't do a lot of
this I do maybe two of these a month but
some people say that the questions and
the the flight over as they're coming
because they're considering now dude how
am I going to use this 60 Minutes you
know even is beneficial to them because
they're starting to really lock in on
what is it they want to because you
don't want to spend 100 Grand right but
what kind of question and answer can be
$100,000 worth of value that's what I'm
wondering cuz can't they like do it for
maybe like 10% the C like 10 grand like
trying to negotiate you know what I mean
like yeah but I'm not doing it for 10
grand so true that's a different that's
a different audience a different gig a
different pitch so like I'm not doing it
so where do you think your experti like
I could come to you guys and say look
guys I'll give you 100 grand
I don't I don't care what period of time
I in less than 15 minutes tell me how to
get my YouTube channel from 2 and a half
million followers to 4.5 I do it for a
lot less but Jack would do it for free
yeah I do it for free good let's do it
for free then man [__] that's even
better but where do you think your
expertise is but I'll pay more attention
if I pay 100 true that's that's a good
point that's a very good point you know
most people just never pay attention
because they don't pay right where do
you think your expertise is if someone's
paying you that much for Consulting
where is your experience in that depends
business is it marketing is it sales is
it real estate no I think it's all you
know I I have I've been blessed to be to
learn a lot about all those like you
know in the beginning was a sales guy I
mean in the very beginning was like how
to get off of drugs the first time you
go to a treatment center yeah like the
failure rate there is about
78% I was one of those 22% that never
went back never used drug in never
relapsed so that was a that that's
something I know how to do and that's
all I do is I just share with people
things that I've learned how to do sales
I'm an excellent salesperson I could
help any organization in the world not
just double triple or quadruple but I
believe 10x are sales because there's so
many missed opportunities on marketing I
mean I've done a decent job of marketing
so only thing I ever share with anybody
is like what what I did that works it's
not like I'm a genius I'm like these
things worked these things didn't MH you
know and they never worked farse but
these things worked and the mistakes we
made in between those two uh the real
estate I you know I bought a lot of Real
Estate so uh I've never lost money in a
real estate deal but I've made mistakes
in real estate so what you learned from
those uh I crowdfunded yeah yeah I well
what I did was I didn't buy enough real
estate that was the number one biggest
mistake I mean I should have bought more
real estate in all Cycles including this
one that's going on uh but like I
crowdfunded we crowdfunded a billion
dollars over the internet I learned a
lot about crowdfunding I didn't know how
to do it I didn't even know what it was
I didn't know what the term was what I'm
curious you said that there's 78%
failure rate out of those drug rehabs
why did you succeed when most people
don't like what was it I can't pinpoint
like whatever other power it's a
characteristic trait or something that
you what I did was I when I got home
that's what I'm saying other than God
you know having something to do with it
um when I came home I got rid of all my
friends I didn't go back to the places
that I went to I got rid of my
girlfriend she was still a drug addict
uh I went to three meetings every every
day every single day in the morning at
noon and at night I went to a meeting I
I was either working on my work or I was
working on helping somebody else and I
did that for five years every single day
how did you get into drugs where did
that start introduce you yeah I was 15
or 16 years almost 16 years old and my
dad had died six years earlier so I was
already starting to have problems
because I was drifting and school was
very slow for me my uncles I was hoping
somebody would come and Mentor me and um
it's probably why I give so much time
away today except
Alex you know uh but I did give him time
right so so um we I had three uncles and
I'm like okay I know those guys are
going to step in and help me they were
busy they got their own lives and nobody
stepped in and then and I was 16 years
old and a drug dealer stepped in and
said hey I'll help you I'll give you
attention is what you need to learn and
the next thing you know I'll go down the
drug Road man it was nasty so for like
nine nine and a half years I just went
South and didn't plan on doing that yeah
you know did it start with like one drug
and then started started with weed weed
is a gateway
drug I 100% agree I agree and people in
high school in middle school they used
to clown on it and be like no weed not
weed's not a gateway drug you're not
just going to go from weed to cocaine
it's like no no it 100% is a gateway
drug you say it isn't you will be proven
dead wrong and it's going to be sad dude
alcohol is a gateway drug if you're
around people that have drugs there's
any mind altering anything is a gateway
to that compromises your ability to make
good decisions you know the moment
you're like okay maybe it's not that big
a deal I mean it does it didn't matter
like people were like hey what was your
drug of choice what what what drug do
you have that's the drug a choice at
this moment that like it didn't did it
ever concern you at that point for like
health or like this could kill me or was
it just like it wasn't my health dude it
was like I wasn't thinking about okay
this is bad for my lungs or bad for my
brain I was like I couldn't quit Okay
literally I started 16 and within a year
I am using some kind of drug every day I
don't know what flip what Flip swi Flip
switch but it also you know you walk
into this new environment of people and
that's what they're doing you know and I
I was surrounded we talk you I know you
guys talk a lot about your environment
who you hanging around who you spend
time with and I had so much free time as
a kid you know different than today I
finished that event up the street you
guys I jump in your car I come over here
I can't get in trouble today right you
know too bu I'm too busy to get in
trouble how are you affording the habit
back then cuz that seems expensive like
every day it's what 20 20 bucks I'm
guess what every every drug uh drug uh
drug addict does is they they buy enough
to use themselves and then they their
friends get drugs you're not using drugs
by yourself I mean I'm I wasn't Whitney
you're kind of selling them as well on
the side and you're just trading drugs
back and forth to people you know you
you nobody's really selling anything
it's it's just
everybody's you know like me coming here
today how do you get a YouTube how do
you get YouTube you guys trade favors
between one another you have enough
guests to have some content so this is
kind of a dismal thought but I have to I
feel like I want to know the answer I I
hear from a lot of different people that
have done drugs extreme drugs in the
past they say the hardest part about
doing drugs is not necessarily the the
suffering that occurs while you're
taking the drug but it's the difference
of perspective and lens that you see
life through for the rest of your life
knowing that the the pleasure that you
can get out of a drug is 10x for a
better you know I mean what everything
else consequentially will happen in your
life you know what I mean like when
you're high on heroin or smack or
something I don't I don't know real so
so my my reality is it is and no one
will ever know until they go down this
road the degradation the personal loss
of self-esteem and disgust with yourself
is so immense and there's nothing like
today there's nothing attractive about
getting hi to meat but but like
conversely in order to put yourself
through that the pleasure had to be so
immense that it was worth it still right
or was it some other chemical thing
going on that like yeah it's a it's a on
once the body starts consuming something
sugar alcohol drugs the body the body
stores this stuff and then it says hey
when you GNA feed me man let's go that's
good to know I always thought that was
kind of a so but I don't wake up in the
morning say oh man I'd love to have some
heroin today it' be such a great state
you know like all I want to eat every
day is help people I still want to help
people like helping people is the the
greatest high in the world yeah and and
then I want to defend my position with
people that think I'm wrong or want to
hate on me or whatever I like I like
that action that's fun for me and then I
want to be I want to create success for
myself and my family so that's a good
segue drug of choice that's a good segue
because we have um some interesting
beliefs that you've said about money
that I think would make great
discussions you started by saying a
million dollars is nothing and you
should never take advice from a million
yeah could you explain your thoughts on
that did I offend you guys no not really
don't we don't get offend it I think
it's impossible to offend us no I I you
know I I say these things out of
Discovery out of personal Discovery
right so like when I when I I was taking
advice from a millionaire and and for
millionaires guys that had made money
and what happens is when a guy goes from
nothing and makes a million dollars
something immediately changes in this
cat most most of them not all of them
but the ones that hit millionaire status
go into conservation and I see this I
see this a majority of the time it is
not a minority but a majority of the
time the guy goes into conservation now
that he has money he's won something
right he's like okay now what do I do I
got to protect the money now I'm going
to save money now I'm going to get an
IRA I'm gonna get a 401k I'm GNA make a
you know I'm gonna pay my house down
they start storing stuff and that's not
what got them the million dollars they
actually violate their own power
condition although before we go into
that as a business owner myself as Ram
knows and as you probably know if you're
a business owner as well staying
organized when you're trying to use a
bunch of different softwares can be
incredibly challenging but with today's
sponsor netw Suite all you have to do is
remember these three numbers 37,000 25
and 1 37,000 because 37,000 companies
have switched to netsuite and stopped
doing things like manual data entry and
searching for scattered information by
hand 25 because netsuite has spent 25
years helping businesses drive down
their costs and one because netsuite is
an all-in-one solution that allow you to
manage all of your kpis or keep
performance indicators with one
efficient system net can help reduce
mistakes from manual data entry and
trust me there's always going to be
mistakes when you're doing it manually
and prevent the busy work from scaling
with your business so get a full picture
of your business and help make better
decisions faster make sure to download
netsuite's popular kpis checklist right
now for free at netsuite.com once again
it's netsuite.com to get your free kpi
checklist guys it's free there's no risk
we strongly recommend it netsuite.com
thank you so much netu and back to the
podcast couldn't you say that a person
who has a million dollars for the most
part he's as close to broke as you can
but they have enough to live a
reasonable lifestyle like 4% withdrawal
rate 40 Grand a year you know but but
it's but let's just say what if we turn
he's only got 25 years before he's out
of money what if invested and it's you
know growing at 7% you can safely
withdraw 4% most of them are not
invested most of them are sitting in
garbage accounts they don't even know
what is but if you do have a million
dollars right and you allocate that in a
way that does give you some form of does
have new income is does he what does he
have new income yeah for the million
dollars you would yeah I me it would be
because we're assuming they have a
million ,000 a year to live off of his
rent's 2500 bucks a month his car 774
he's broke I think and he's worried
every day about going backwards every
cutting it close cutting it close C
close it it's ridiculous dude million
like nobody this million millionaire
concept has been around for my entire
lifetime I'm 65 years old okay my entire
lifetime ever since Money Millionaire
was the deal so with inflation you Haven
consider a million a million today or
when the term millionaire grew in
popularity I think was a
1920 and I think adjusted for inflation
that would be the equivalent today of
like $17 million it was wild it's more
like this okay okay 1958 when I was born
$1
today is worth 10
cents so that is 10x okay so a million
dollars in
1958 you would need $10 million today
now you get the $10 million now you have
a little bit of like okay I'm cool I'm
cool I got a little bit of movement okay
you think you can then go into
conservation when is conservation you
should never go into conservation but
doesn't it make sense at a certain point
I mean I guess I guess if you want to
conserve cool but I don't like you know
that's not my game my game is you know
but let's just say for the average and
10 million doesn't get you Freedom what
you can't even lose your YouTube account
what price what price how much money do
you need for Freedom you guys can't
cover Co you can't cover Malone you
can't cover j6 I don't think those are
our topics I mean those we don't you
went hard at it your channel would be
shut down here's the thing if you have
10 million bucks and your lifestyle is
costing you 150 Grand a year you have
enough where if something were to happen
to the channel you could survive
comfortably and still have a little bit
of a buffer on $10 million but where's
the point that you think you're living
off of 400 Grand a year correct yeah
okay but where's the point you get
Freedom at what level of we well it
ain't at 400 Grand a year income is it
is it a million year you're still flying
American and if American don't fly you
don't fly so you you you don't have
freedom yet let's just keep it real so
how if you don't like your house anymore
and you got $5 million in your house and
you're like the housing market sucks and
I got to sell my house for 3 million you
don't have that you don't have that
freedom to say I'm going to lose money
and move cuz I just want to don't want
to be here anymore so you're speaking
based off of your own standards no no
I'm saying based on math man this is not
about me this is [__] math so but the
number what's the number what's the
number how much do you need is it100
million it depends on what kind of it
depends on what kind of sty class of
life you want do you want your kids in
public schools or even private schools
today but that goes down to like a 3% 4%
withdrawal rate so on $10 million
$400,000 a year assuming you don't have
kids you don't really need you're going
to spend the next 25 years consuming
your money and you're going to be brok
by the time you're dead but then what's
the point of having 33 33 so you're
going to be 58 years old and you had 10
million and you're broke now well that's
assuming I spent all of it though well
you're you're spending 400 Grand a year
yeah but if you invest the money a 3%
withdrawal rate why you investing it
though I thought you had enough well you
have to invested if you want the
money you would just keep you wouldn't
just keep cash we're assuming that if
you have 10 million it's not like you
just keep it in cash and it's safe and
just you're you're not you're not you're
not assuming also that you have 25 years
of of Def of that dollar that's true
okay most people their Investments are
not even keeping up with inflation today
that is true but how many investors I
think are terrible I think the average
investor makes like 2.3% a year the S&P
returns eight and a half give or take
well but the average only returns eight
and a half Stephen because they they
continue to rotate the winners in the
S&P 500 but that's how it works since
it's weighted by market count yeah well
you got seven stocks holding up the
whole time right now so if I'm not in
those seven you know or if I wasn't in
it at the right point I'm just saying
most people do not see their I mean I
know that that is the pitch right that
everybody earns seven or eight% but
that's not really what's happening for
people but let's say they earn 7% in
real estate okay then that would be
different for you if you have $10
million you're not heavily invested in
real estate why wouldn't you be really
I'm just saying how much real estate can
you buy with $10 million $5 million
property cash let's just say paid off
true $5 million and or 4 million ow 300
Grand a year maybe yeah that's right so
he's got 300 Grand coming in it will
grow it will be there for him he has no
debt on it that's a great that's a great
plan I love that plan yeah do you think
at your level of wealth you have
complete
Freedom no where is your freedom
restricted my freedom is restricted if I
wanted to
buy uh master class that's probably
going to go bankrupt I'm going to have
two two guys there that that bidding on
the same company right and the Comm
maybe um make the deal happen faster
than I can let's say let's say I wanted
to buy a Reit right now
for um this $25 billion but it's I know
it in the future it'll be worth a
hundred I probably don't have the
freedom to go make that to make more
money no it would be to make
moves it would be to like it would be to
make plays I guess logic it would be to
create it would create Legacy you guys
are talking about me buying another
watch I watch here's so you get
fulfillment and enjoyment out of
movement and growth and stuff like that
so that is why
yous whereas a lot of people it's kind
of a means to an end of like living a
life being able to afford the watch that
they want and stuff like that but for
you that is the end I said earlier man
success is my drug of choice like I like
playing the game I like winning right so
it's not about I got I got a decent
plane so I don't need you know I don't
need another one you walk us through the
logistics how much was the plane and how
much does it cost to run uh man he
jumped pretty quick right there here is
before we go off on another topic I want
I want to H on this the Gulf Stream 650
it's an ER it's extended range so it can
go from Miami to Dubai non-stop it's a
magnificent plane and it was a 20201
2020 it's a it was a brand new plane I
bought it actually from a guy in ch in
in Russia an olard right before Ukraine
happened and um that plane's 70 million
bucks and then it'll it'll cost three to
three and a half million bucks a year to
run whether so when you when you paid
$70 million you got a loan and
everything or like what does it look
like to actually go what did I do on
that deal I I sold my 550 I sold that to
Tim Draper uh I think I got what was the
number I got on that plane anyway we did
that we do have a a small loan on the
plane I I don't exactly know what it is
right now as we sit my understanding
these are good tax writeoffs all of it
yeah do you wrote all of it off that
year I don't think we we're in in at 70
million I think we're in at 64 million
63 million something like that and then
that that would become a tax deduction
against earned income that same year
even though I only I took delivery of
the plane like in December only had it
like for 17 days took one flight in it
and rode off 63 million that's a great
headline for your video do you manage
your own wealth or do you have a team
that manages it you manage it so so like
that when that there is no one I take
Financial advice from is is that private
jet is that
onay that note is on on autopay or like
yeah 100% okay
yeah so I'm curious you said like even
is the management company right there's
a management company that manages a
plane so there's two pilots there
full-time oh so it's all that just kind
of yeah there's money going to the
management company the fuel Bill comes
through them I've never looked about
fuel you you don't know what it costs
the fuel never it's just a negligible
amount of money at this point because no
no no it's not negligible the plane's no
good without
fuel so it's just it doesn't even matter
it is a would you consider the cost of
these microphones when when building a
podcast I think we did we did we
shouldn't have we really shouldn't have
you're not going to have a podcast
without us right well we could have G
cheaper microphone right but we decided
to go with the industry standard The Joe
Rogan podcast or the Jo mic yeah what
yeah of course you could have gone you
could have G with one that doesn't have
this this going spin I don't know why
that's doing it's oh your look I know
the cost of everything in my life
literally like everything I have never
ever asked for the cost of the gas and
the reason why the fuel the reason why
is because the plane cannot fly without
the fuel so it doesn't even matter it's
a what do you call that elastic good
it's a constant it's required it's a
it's a it's a facility do you budget or
do you no not well neither does gram gr
doesn't budget either so but I'm just
curious disciplined with my money like I
I live so below my means I have four
cars two here and two in Malibu or two
in Miami yeah I don't have a fleet of
cars what cars do you have we have a a g
a g wagon I have a G wagon an Escalade
in Malibu and now I have a Rolls colan
on a lease a r Range Rover how much it
cost to lease of Rolls-Royce colon I
feel like we're just doing trivial
question I'm just curious it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter okay it doesn't matter but so I'm
not extravagant okay all my stuff is
paid for I have no debt anywhere in my
life nowhere except my cash flow
producing real estate the apartment in
the jet uh well yeah whatever I mean
it's negligible right yeah you're right
um but but yeah so yeah I got out of a
company that does probably 150 million a
year every year that's the our Miami
company based company um we have that
little bit of debt on the plane but that
plane that plane dude is like I would
never give that plane up I'm giving my
kids up you know what's funny papa John
said the same they say the exact same
thing he's like I don't need anything
except for my jet I need the private jet
and the guys that own Yachts say hey
I'll give up my plane but I'm not giving
up my yacht it's just there's l to this
guess there's levels to the game man and
when you grow when you grow up the way I
grew up you don't know about the levels
so you think I don't need that I never
thought about a plane in my life ever NE
never had the fantasy never had it on a
list never have it on a bucket list I
got to have a plane but I also didn't
have on a bucket list that I would own
companies and I would be the boss never
I was forced into a boss situation it
wasn't like something I was some Law of
Attraction stuff yeah but you even
mentioned uh in terms of managing your
own money I understand that but even the
tax side of things you're the one who
does the your research and fig out
research how do you learn how to do all
all because I feel like the tax code
changes so frequently it's like every
years I read it and then I call my
accountant and say hey do this and then
he says oh that can't be done I'm like
you don't understand the code dude like
let's me and you get together don't
charge me for this I'm going to charge
you 100 Grand not 600 bucks an hour and
I'm going to educate you on this damn
tax code because the way I read that we
can do this this and this and then he'll
tell me no no no because of blah blah
blah do you ever deal with audits I've
had four audits I wanton them all as you
might have noticed Grant Cardone is
constantly improving on things and when
it comes to that AI could be the most
important new computer technology ever
and just like a nimbus cloud it is
storming every industry and literally
billions of dollars are being invested
Jack it's cumulon nimus that's the storm
cloud okay well just buckle up and bring
your umbrella the problem is that AI
needs a ton of speed and processing
power so how do you compete without the
cost getting out of of control well it's
time to upgrade to the next generation
of the cloud like a cirrus cloud no Jack
Oracle Cloud infrastructure or oci
that's great I like this show and it's
good cuz people are learning types of
clouds oci is a single platform for your
infrastructure database application
development and AI needs oci has four to
eight times the bandwidth of other
clouds offers one consistent price
instead of variable Regional pricing and
of course nobody does data better than
Oracle so now you can train your AI
models at twice the speed and less than
half the cost of other clouds like a
cirrus cloud or like a Stratus like an
oci Cloud if you want to do more and
spend less like uber 8x8 in datab bricks
Mosaic take a free test drive of oci at
oracle.com that's oracle.com slist once
again oracle.com get a free test drive
free okay we all love free once again
oracle.com I thank you so much Oracle
and back to the podcast and what's that
process like is that terrible worst
thing particularly in California
California is the
worst uh they're worse than the federal
IRS because they're broke and they're
coming after you with everything do they
like even even if you know what to do on
this even if you know what to do that
you're right you still have to hire a
probably an ex
IRS uh litigator to defend you because
they're going to bury you in paperwork
four years four audits after I left the
state of California yeah so were those
residency audits of them claiming that
no you still did business in California
or were those like you left and they're
trying to they they they tried to say
that I left incorrectly oh wow they lost
that one so the second one was um I
forget what the second one was this has
been years ago but the fourth one was
you did a a deal you had some real
estate in California you did a 1031 into
another deal and when you gave your
partner who had no
equity uh a bonus he moved to a
different LLC and when you did it
violated the 1031 like they were looking
at everything by this time and I said I
appeal it they said we knew you would
we've already um we've already denied
your appe appeal I said like you don't
even you haven't even got my appeal
we're denying it before you appeal it
that's how nasty like that's just
California that's after you had left
just like total communism how many years
after you left almost seven seven years
after you left they came after it four
audits the fourth one the seventh year
is it so isn't that the the maximum that
they have is it seven years yeah I don't
I think I think they have is whatever
term they want I think they they could
figure because they they'll tell you
look if you don't pay this 750,000 which
is what it was if you don't pay the 750
we'll freeze your accounts I'm like
freeze my accounts my accounts are in
Miami they said we can freeze your
accounts anywhere in the world wow I was
like wow do you ever worry about never
being satisfied or you think the pursuit
of that is more important yeah I'm I'm
never I'm not interested in being
satisfied it's not even a fulfilled
though it's not a goal I am fulfilled
it's not I am fulfilled like but
I'm not satisfied I'm full of that
little sandwich that I took three bites
of but I'm not and it wasn't very
satisfying was it good no it was it was
it was it's some fuel for me to get
through this interview right and then
and then it's like but but you know am I
satisfied am I oh my God that was amaz
no it wasn't amazing it was just Fuel
and and so is life and so is what I've
done up to this point it's cool what
I've done I think I can do more than
this you know I was interviewing Tom
Brady you know and I kept saying Tom man
why do you like the wind so much he's
like I don't want to let anybody down I
said Tom come on tell me the real thing
bro like how good are those Rings he's
like no man I don't want to let anybody
down I'm like come on Tom it's [__]
why do you like the win so much cuz this
guy is so intense and he says Grant I
don't want to let anyone down and I said
and what about you and he's like yeah I
don't want to let myself down it's him
it's not his mom and his dad and his
it's him he don't want to let himself
down he thinks I said bro you ain't how
can you let yourself down he's like
because I know I can do more but when he
was a kid you know when he was getting
drafted or not drafted for the NFL he
probably thought man if I could just get
drafted and then he did and then he won
then he's like oh if I could just get
one ring and then he's like once he gets
the ring all these guys tell me the same
thing by the way once you get one ring
you want two and I don't think he's
going to be satisfied with seven rings I
think he's going to retire now and say
okay what can I do that's bigger than
rings and what about happiness if if we
changing our metric from like
fulfillment right or satisfaction like
happiness General happiness you would
say you're happy or would where would
you say you fall I don't I don't measure
it you don't measure why why would you
measure never think about it okay I
don't like have a little Smiley thing on
my on my do you think it's important to
measure happiness like think about this
okay you have what two daughters correct
yeah beautiful daughters okay so your
daughters yeah would you want them to be
happy no I want them to be productive
and they will be happy to the degree
they're productive okay if they're Free
Loaders in society they will not be
happy no matter how much money you no
matter what their car looks like their
room looks like their clothes look like
if they're not productive members
contributing to society it is impossible
to be happy you really think so do you
think it's possible to be happy without
being productive or you have to be
prodive to Bey I don't know anybody that
is happy without being productive do you
I do agree I think I think productivity
is a a huge indicator of happiness or or
I would say a cause of Happiness right I
I but I don't know if it's like a one to
one ratio I think of be responsibility
right do you have responsibilities that
you take care of every single day akin
to produc yeah yeah yeah I would say
it's a Kinder productivity watch I'm I'm
I'm going to make my bed that's
production MH can you be productive
though without being happy yes can you
be productive without being if you're if
you're if you're productive you're going
to be happy like if I go mow the lawn
right and then I then I do a great job
and then I put all the leaves to in a b
uh in a bag and put them out on the curb
and they get picked up and I dude I'm
happy about my work but that's only
going to last so long because that grass
is going to grow grow again I'm like
[__] I got to do it again so what would
you say to someone now who's unhappy
with their life and they want to change
things around what would you tell them
to do I would tell them to quit seeking
happiness and start seeking prod
productivity and contribution and
helping other people and improving the
quality of life and quit shopping for
happy and like like like even when we
have this money conversation like your
your your your whole comment section is
gonna when we talked about 10 million 50
million 100 million whatever it is your
comment section I've seen all this
there's nothing going to surprise me is
going to fill up with but he's not happy
okay I can tell he's is he happy and
what dude what we're not happy is a
different topic even in your in your
questions money and happiness should not
even be a considered Blended topic they
have nothing to do with one another okay
it'd be like me going to Whole Foods
looking for lowfat milk in the happy
counter like I'm looking for lowfat milk
okay oh if you get that milk and eat
right doesn't mean you're going to be
happy they got nothing to do with one
another I'm not looking for money in
order to be happy but isn't there like
studies that have shown that money and
happiness past a certain point actually
past it have an inverse relationship
actually there's reports out there
saying rich people are happier than poor
people so we had a good discussion with
Tai Lopez on this he said the happiest
people that doesn't have enough
money to have an opinion on this WOW
shot fire
and I love by the way but I don't think
Tai has enough bank yet to actually have
his own personal opinion he could recite
some philosopher which he probably did
shots fired Ty no so but Tai's anecdotal
stories we're talking about other people
that he's witnessed people who are worth
a billion dollars people who are poor he
said the happiest people that he had
seen are people earning between1 and $3
million a year yeah they flew under the
radar they had enough to get by and have
95% of the same choices as everybody
else the same doors same opportunities
and they were local celebrities were
basically they weren't too they as he
called it they weren't Kings the Kings
get shot down they're they're the
princes where where they're too small to
attack but they're getting Buy on one to
three million first of all there's no
way he could have do a survey that would
be accurate to even say that that that
that is like completely impossible for
him to run some kind of calculation
saying it's people between one and three
million that that were prin is not Kings
and they lived in a local place and they
were celebrities I mean it's impossible
so number one number two like I know
guys that have worth1 billion and are
not happy and I know people that have 12
cents and they'll never be happy and and
I'm just telling you if you give me one
or two of those okay I don't want to be
unhappy and no money and anybody has no
money can't be happy it's impossible
because if I have no
money I'm worried about my next
meal okay it's at that point if I'm
scared I'm not happy scared people are
not happy people they're scared people
you know what his example of that though
was the Amish okay the Amish had very
little
money the happiest people he's ever met
okay well that's not one to three
million those are farmers disconnected
from society disconnected from
television disconnected from social
media of course they're going to be
happier right but me how many how many
of your audience is willing to be trade
in uh whatever they're doing right now
to be Amish for their happiness I doubt
very very many I'd be curious to try it
though I would try it yeah how long how
long you going to try it uh I mean I
wouldn't abandon all my current
responsibilties you didn't even do the
yacht trip long
enough how you going to do the
trip that's funny yeah but I feel like
the one thing yach aquariums out there
in forland the issue with the yacht is
that there was nothing to work on for me
is that anything you wanted was there
you you ask them for a meal they bring
it to you turning butter stacking hay
perhaps that would lead to more
fulfillment like I got to work on these
things today the sun's going down I got
to get this done by this time you're
back to production right so you say that
happiness is way too arbitrary that it
doesn't even make sense to necessarily
be measuring it measure productivity
which is actually can be measured right
yeah I yeah I I like that I like that I
just think a lot of people are searching
try want to be happy thinking they're
entitled to to happiness and they
haven't even done anything and why am I
entitled to it why why do you know just
cuz you live in America you think the
Hamas right now are happy or or the Gaza
Strip people the Palestinians or Gaza
Strip or the Israelis that are attacking
nobody over there is looking for happy
they're looking for survival right now
but here in America we're like man I
deserve to be happy and I deserve my
Starbucks okay and I deserve air
condition and you don't deserve any of
that stuff that's all I'm saying I'm
like you're lucky to have air condition
or or one drink a week but most of us
take that for granted and then pile on
top of that I deserve to be happy too I
could could agree with that more while
I'm eating [__] Foods mhm spent 12 years
in a [__] education I'm not being paid
enough money once I get my million
dollars I don't know what to do with it
and now I'm supposed to be happy and I
don't know how to be in a relationship
with another human being but I should be
happy I also think that there's
something in like the pursuit of
happiness or pursuing anything in
general will lead to you not being
necessarily like content or satisfied
with the results because there like you
said there's always like another step I
AG with that I agree with that but but
I think that that's fine I think that
that not being content there's there's
these guys that I Mee and they're like
they have this what's the word they have
this sense they have this sense of U
scarcity no it's a discontent it's a
it's a Divine Divine discontent if God
was content he would have stopped doing
a lot of things like he you know if you
believe in God creating everything he he
could have stopped at mountains and
valleys he could have stopped at men
only and not added the women
we wouldn't have freaking fish and
octopus and animals under you know it's
close to home man don't say that like
you go too you go under water you go we
we we haven't even discovered 90% of the
life underwater like the Miracles
underwater like and and yet people are
like I deserve a coffee and we haven't
even discovered the pursuit of the rest
of the adventures of life I like that
I'll be a til Lopez real quick and in
the wise words of Victor Frankle
happiness is not something to be pursued
but it ends so it follows Ty gave you
that no that's Victor Frankl but I'm
saying I'm ty Lopez I'm quoting somebody
else speaking of mistakes that people
make one of the things that you said we
really liked uh this a direct quote
direct buying a home is one of the
dumbest effing things a human can do
with their money when we see that is
like that's one of the ways that people
build wealth like a vast majority of
people is when they buy their house
right okay you don't build you don't
build wealth like that okay expand okay
so so Orange County average home here is
800,000 bucks Vegas is going to be 450
maybe
490 okay so what what you're going to
build you're going to go buy a house for
$500,000 in Las Vegas 800,000 in Orange
County you're going to
put 20% down 20% down 15 20 you're going
to put
$160,000 I'll do math on both of them
160,000 here in Orange County and you're
going to put down what is it 100 Grand
over there that money's dead that money
could have been put in yourself just the
down payment you could have invested in
yourself in your business there's not a
business or an individual that can't
produce more Revenue than a single
family home sitting on 22nd Street okay
it just sits there the only thing worse
than investing in a house is giving
money to the bank and letting them have
it okay the bank benefits particularly
in this environment today Bank of
America is going to charge you 8% for 10
years let's say you stay in that house
for 10 years you're in Vegas okay you
paid
500 okay
you put a loan on it you put 8% on
$400,000 that's 30 what is that 32,000 a
year time 10 is 320 that's your interest
on the first 10 years so you need to
sell your house for 500 plus 320 to
break even you haven't paid property
taxes maintenance nor have you counted
the fact that your 100 Grand was dead it
could have been invested in something
else I'm just saying compared to other
Investments S&P 500 okay if you I think
what's difficult today is that what
you're saying right now makes sense to
me yeah and I agree with you completely
I think right now is one of the few
times I just financially speaking I
don't see the benefit of buying anything
right now the last property I bought was
2020 because interest rates are so high
when I look at the cost of buying versus
renting renting is like half price na
it's insane so when I look at the two
I'm like why buy a house right now it
doesn't make any sense financially
unless you plan to live there for 30
years but as a general saying I think
for me 10 years ago I would have said
buy something I think for a lot of
people a savings but right now it's kind
of skewed I feel yeah but I think for
you how many people do you know have
ever kept a house 30 years some of the
investors I used to work with and what
they would do is they'd buy a house fix
it up move in themselves live there 5 10
years keep that as a rental then move on
to the next one and repeat the process
maybe every 5 10 years they'll buy a
house and 30 years they you know have a
few houses so that's not a good
investment man it's not it's period
you'd be better off buying YouTube ads I
think it when we look you make more
money on your YouTube channel than you
will on this house appreciating this
house but if you look at the success and
failure rates of people that will try to
do something like that you discount the
fact that there's 40 million people in
America lost money on the house between
2005 and
2012 that's only if they sold well dude
they had to sell they couldn't there's
there's there's still millions of of
homes on foreclosures we forget all this
stuff you forget CNBC makes sure that
everybody forgets all the losses in the
stock market every day we forget about
bank failures we've had three major bank
failures just 16 months ago we had the
biggest bank failure in the history of
the United States and everybody's forgot
it like it didn't didn't even happen I
think a lot of that is really just
bailouts but those losses are only
realized to people sell now I I know on
paper obviously if you buy in 2005
you've lost a substantial amount of
money in 2011 but for those people who
held today they're still sitting on
quite a a lot of profit maybe not as
much as in stocks or other Investments
it's not a good investment though I
think the argument is that people have
to live some average person that's what
I'm trying to get out because if you
look at like I said real data of the
people that the number one wealth
Builder is your primary home and then
you compare that to the data that shows
that I don't know what percent it is but
I'm sure it's an exorbitant percent of
business owners fail right yeah then and
you compare the two and you're like you
should always be a business owner when
the data is suggesting otherwise
wouldn't that make sense that for the
average person that maybe doesn't have
the discipline that maybe doesn't have
like the I don't know the motivation to
continue pushing with a business and
perseverance because they're they're
being told a bunch of [__] like hey
buy a house buy a house and one day
you're going to be fine invest in Ira
you're going to be fine get a get a 401k
contribute as much as you can you're
going to be fine one day you're going to
be fine Social Security is going to take
care of you people are being told a
bunch of lies and then they lay down and
say it's going to be fine they said I'm
going to be fine if I just do these
things I'm going to be all right if I
buy a house I'm going to be all right
but we know that most Americans are
living paycheck to paycheck have less
than 5200 bucks in a savings account
okay their Ira will not take care of
them at retirement Social Security is
going to fail in this country in your
lifetimes it will fail okay the US
dollar is likely to fail people know it
yet they save it so the reason people
don't hustle is because they've been
told by the government you guys are cool
you're in the middle class you got a
good job you got air condition you got
your little latte okay you deserve
happiness okay you got your Whole Foods
account and we might relieve your
college you got a college education so
you're better educated than most people
you got a car mortgage like you freaking
strapped up to here you got 30% of
people like failing on on uh 33% of the
American public today got a second job
because they can't fund their activities
you got car car delinquencies going
through the roof at the all-time highest
credit card debt highest ever so
whatever everybody's been told ain't
working for most of these people these
average people that you're talking about
so you're saying that people should
instead of going down the more
traditional route that could be more
safe but also subject to other external
things such as like the the government
and the stability of the dollar you
think people should go For Broke like go
For Broke meaning like you know shoot
for the the moon and then if you miss
you're just in outer space somewhere
right with nothing you'd say that is a
optimal just fundamentally you could
literally go For Broke that is the
better and you would be rewarded in this
country you could go For Broke you
cannot go to jail going for broke but
you can play it safe and guarant almost
guarantee you will end up broke I agree
that you should that a lot of people
should go For Broke when they don't yeah
but with the stipulation with the caveat
that if you miss that you continue
trying and trying and trying and trying
trying try and I think that's extremely
important to include that and that's why
so many businesses fail because they try
it fails and they go to some like you
know a more stable thing where they're
not a business owner or something like
that or why 9% of day Traders lose is
because they just try it they lose money
and they're like ah I'm not going to you
know I'm not going to continue trying
learning a stupid business no I'm just
saying like why these Fringe things are
so un quick always fails exactly
business owning is also I mean it kind
of is marketed in the same way of like
hey you're going to be able to work from
your laptop and you're going to be able
to drop sh and this and that make a
bunch of money in your first year and I
think that it's really important to
include that caveat that like you're
likely not going to be successful for a
long time and you just have to push
through all of that and then I I agree
with you I think that a lot of people
could go that route but for the average
person if we're looking at all available
data yeah they are better off I would
this is what I would say doing that if
they don't have doing the stable thing
work better off going to work for
somebody else than themselves right and
I would agree but if they have the
perseverance and motivation than they
could do the business owning route but
they just better be ready to weather the
storm you know yeah I think statistics
on that only 20% of business owners make
more than a W2 employee and they work
way more hours I do think they could be
successful that small you know people
that are successful I think it could be
bigger if they just don't give up and
they learn from their failures rather
than like Let It absorb them and then
they go to something more stable because
they're so sh shi shi away from it but
what about last thing on the house
though Elon owns Elon owns no houses
Warren Buffett has the same house he
always has the point is they didn't try
to create wealth in this fixed asset
class that does not cash flow does not
provide get great ta tax writeoffs and
historically over the last 50 years I
don't know why people get so upset with
me on this house thing
because it's just not a great deal
as opposed to now if you're not going to
do anything if you're just going to get
a job save some money and not and just
be a renter for the rest of your life
and you're going to stay in the same
place forever and you know that just
make sure you're buying in a great
marketplace where there's going to be
positive job growth only about 10% of of
America U there's about 10 cities in
America where 90% of all the people live
the rest of these places where people
live are never going to go up in value I
think we all fundamentally agree on this
at once we're kind of understanding the
other person's position to the full get
through this inflation issue that we're
that that's being fabricated right now
we're going to on the other side of this
is going to be massive deflation so that
leads us perfectly you also said Lewis
house man here we go inflation is a
boogeyman it isn't real you said that on
Lewis house yeah yeah why is inflation
not real because you can't really
measure it right you can't you can
measure it at the store and say eggs are
too much but I could
absolutely control that by not buying
eggs inflation was caused by the supply
chains being blocked during covid not
because money was too cheap if I print
and your audience is going to go nut
Bonkers on this we'll love this okay
they're going to go Bonkers so when you
print a trillion dollars we put a
trillion dollars in this big building
right here which I don't think it would
fit we have not created because of
printing inflation now I could be wrong
on this but but this is my
hypothesis printing money does not
create inflation now I distribute the
trillion because if I haven't
distributed did nobody knows anything
happened right now Distributing the
three of us each get a third of a
trillion I would love that
dude what we going to do you GNA buy a
jet yeah I'll buy a jet you could buy
you could buy 10 PL maybe a nicer
microphone if I really want to splurge
right yeah you can buy you can buy you
could buy a media company you could buy
a CNN now bro okay like the think just
right okay so we distribute to the three
of us but none of us spend our money we
still don't have inflation inflation
only happens when people start using the
money okay now if we go invest in
countries because we got enough money
now to buy countries the entire state of
Hawaii okay we inflate those little
markets those little pockets but we
don't inflate the whole world the whole
world now when you distribute money to
every idiot on the planet okay 1,400
bucks and every idiot says godamn I got
to spend this money I deserve a house I
deserve some Gucci even though it's
covid and I can't even use my Gucci
except in my living room and if I go any
place I got to be 6 feet from somebody
else that's how you cause inflation you
give idiots money to go do dumb [__]
with and that's what they did people did
dumb [__] with money they inflated the
cost of everything people raised their
prices and you guys kept going back and
buying
stuff because the moment the the demand
for an for for anything stops when the
demand stops prices will fall but
consumers continue to demand that they
deserved great microphones but wouldn't
it be a leading indicator right like
when you know rates are going up then a
business that maybe sells some sort of
product or service they're like well
people are going to have more money I'm
going to change prices maybe before the
Commerce actually starts coming in but
they don't you're saying most businesses
man they're just trying to hang on the
price follows suit after the demand you
can't change the price before the well
you had to have the demand first you you
you you don't you know the price doesn't
change pre demand you get demand you
don't trust it demand hits again you
don't trust it demand happens again or
that was a fluke it was a weekend boom
denn it's demand demand and then you're
like [__] I'm out of inventory okay guys
I'm going to send you I'm going send you
10 more 10 more sets of whatever
basketballs okay and you have orders for
50 of them you're like [__] raise the
price on those 10 basketballs but most
people most businesses lag when they
actually respond to a demand curve but I
think that inflation is is sure it's
real to the the people that are working
the stable job right and then all of the
sudden they see the price of eggs it
increases in the grocery all you have to
do is not buy the eggs I think it's it's
difficult not to buy the eggs when
everything else is also costing more
let's just say gasoline uh it could be
your utilities cost more everything else
in your daily life that you need those
those constants are costing more and
some people would say oil and gas and
electricity could be like my brother
would tell you all of it should be way
more expensive because if it was you
guys wouldn't be burning all these
lights in here so all this stuff all
this electricity going on behind us is
too cheap otherwise they turn them off
again it's a demand thing I demand I'm
I'm willing to pay this price now
alongside with that goddamn eggs are too
much beans are too much okay but why do
you keep complaining and keep buying and
that's what causes inflation so what do
you think is going to happen do you
think eventually prices are going to
rise to a point where they have to come
back down we're already there we're
already on the other side of inflation
we already see it we see it in mortgage
applications you see it in uh prices of
goods inventory uh is sitting in car
dealerships for longer than it ever has
at at levels that they haven't seen I
have a bunch of friends in the car
business uh you're seeing houses not
trade now marget applications at 28y
year lows um I mean if you want to talk
about who's causing damage is Jerome pal
raising interest rates to
8% um and stopping all that activity all
those mortgage brokers that title clerks
uh uh escrow companies that need that
money and that activity you're making it
impossible for people to buy a home
today so how are you using this as an
opportunity to make moves we're buying
every piece of real estate that we can
buy the cash flows right now with no
debt so how are how have you position
your portfolio to whether a potential
storm if prices continue to drop or
interest rates continue to go higher
like for your existing loans let's just
say yeah are those we have 30 39 loans
we have uh uh five of those loans loans
32 of the loans have 10year
mortgages um we have five loans that
have adjustables through 20 what what
are we in 23 through 25 2-year
extensions those will have to be fixed
um it's 15% of the entire portfolio so I
mean I have it charted out exactly what
I'll have to fund to fix all that it
will there's an old adage uh Nathan
Rocha I think said when there's blood in
the Street by comma even when it's your
own blood so we expect to we we have
12,000 apartments right now we expect to
double that portfolio in this cycle
maybe in the next six months do you
worry though about interest rates
resetting at a higher amount well at the
same time rents are falling or you
believe that rents will continue to go
even higher I think rents will flatten I
think rents flatten for the next two
years 24 25 you'll have flat rents and
then in 26 cuz they're not going to
build anything they'll stop all building
all construction this happened again in
20089 and 10 um we're 4 million homes
short in America today we're probably
another 40 million homes that nobody
wants because they're old homes they're
your mom's and Grandma's house nobody
wants to move into them and um in 26 27
rents will explode in this
country the $1900 rent that people are
complain about will be $4,000 see my
thought is that home prices will
eventually come down to a point where
all of a sudden they make sense to buy
again when rents and home prices are
about even and someone could say okay I
know I'm going to be here for eight
years therefore based on this trajectory
I think buying makes more sense and
that's where I feel like the demand has
to go yeah I think we take that $800,000
house in Orange County or the one in
Vegas the one you bought that you regret
now I actually do not regret I think it
was 28 4% on the mortgage 30 years fixed
yeah that's awesome that's awesome
you're going to rent that to somebody
I'm R it well I'm renting four rooms as
as we speak Jack is cash flow this place
let's go man cash flow bro that's what
I'm saying how stupid can you get to
live there for free you can go as stupid
as your cash flow that's the game dude
he's pretty stupid he's got a pingpong
table in the living room yeah it's
awesome that that $500,000 house here or
in Vegas has to go down probably to like
350,000 and the rates have to drop for
him to even compete with an apartment
deal down the street and even when that
happens let's say they they they become
equals $2,000 and $2,000 rent or
mortgage one requires a down payment the
other one doesn't one requires a 30-year
commitment one requires a 10 mon 10mon
uh commitment and one of them does not
have a swimming pool does not have
security does not have a uh does not
have um a theater and the other one
because these are the apartments that
are being built today these are freaking
unbelievable communities theater parking
structure social audience a community
like built in 300 families living around
you that are hopefully not crazy people
so we see a lot of people like in bokeh
we bought a deal in
bokeh the average tenant in the building
makes 400 Grand okay their rent to
income ratio is under 14% they could buy
a house all of them could buy a house
but they don't want it they're like I
don't want a house I don't want to mow a
lawn I don't want to clean the pool I
don't want to fix the Billards the the
table tennis whatever I just want to do
my thing pay my
rent and be mobile go on vacation 75
million Baby Boomers in this country
don't want a house people my age aren't
looking to buy a house you've also said
that if you have your last $1,000 you
recommend that people spend it on
personal development and some form of a
course to increase I know their
knowledge on a given marketable um I
would say thing yeah do you still stand
by that because the way that I you're
already br broke yeah but you could be
more broke you're broke you can't get
more broke than $1,000 $999 no zero zero
or th000 same same number you're broke
already right but but you don't want to
have to you know you get a pothole you
hit a pothole and you pop a tire and you
don't want have to put that on a credit
card 33% so so you hit a pothole you're
telling me fixing your tire is more
important than fixing yourself I just
think that what's the best return you or
the tire I mean you got to say yourself
with with the caveat
Uber for seven bucks dude you're broke
already people need to understand this
goes back to the argument you and I had
earlier okay but an emergency fund is
something you ain't got an emergency
fund bro you got $1,000 that's worth
about a hundred you ain't got an
emergency fund you are broke okay so
when I did that show undercover
billionaire they gave me a hundred bucks
I said I don't need the 100 they're like
oh no it's good for the show we're going
to count it down I'm like what are you
talking about they're like it's going to
go 100 then it's going to go 82 and then
it's going to 76 and then it's going to
go 40 it's going to be great TV I said
no it's not I'm going to take it to the
bank and drop it off and I'm going to go
to zero day one because that 100 cannot
save me I don't need the 100 I don't
need the Thousand I don't need 10 grand
I would tell you spend your last 10
grand you're broke make it official get
a [__] t-shirt I am broke and on the
back and I am
hustling and go get your money man I
stay broke all the time I never have
money I don't keep I don't keep money
because it's not worth anything The Only
Thing Worth anything to me is me and my
hustle and my focus and my go get it I'm
just saying I convinced you I sold no no
dude that's funny that's really funny
here's the thing when you're saying that
I'm like I should just get rid of my
house I should just get rid of my car
give it to me because because because
you have more hustle you got more engine
than your car yeah but I'm it's a
building process right so I I do think T
how old are you man 25 25 bro you got
like you will never be 25 again bro you
got all like if I was 25 years old today
knowing what I know today 40 years
younger man oh my God I'd have my eyes
on 10 billion I don't so crazy okay
here's the thing obviously you should
you write me a check for 10 billion I'll
be happy to cash it the thing is I I
don't necessarily want to make the
sacrifices that a l and look people are
going to Flame me for this because we
have a very hustle cultur audience I
because you're selfish me yes for what
you're like I don't need 10 billion I
ain't talking about you how many people
could you help with 10 billion yes a lot
how much of the world could you help
with 10 billion you're not you're like I
don't need that and you guys ought to
rag on him right now for being so
selfish here's 10 billion Jack is built
differently Jack likes to take it easy
I've tried telling Jack do we got to
work 12 hours a day 12 hours a day 6
days a week I want to be able to text
Jack at 11:00 p.m. instant responses I
want that Jack what about a thousand
communities could have pickle ball
thousand Community could have their
table tennis like you just think about
your table tennis rather than other
communities I help other people I help
other people but you can't help enough
people because you're down to your last
grand you're right you're right I defin
and it is in my Horizon that I do want
to help people but I don't think that
like I wouldn't honestly maybe I'm too
selfish I don't want to get to 10
billion so I can then just help a bunch
of other people I would love to get to a
few million and then help people but I
think that to like spend the time of my
20s and 30s and 40s and 50s and 60s to
get to 10 billion to then like I want to
still enjoy my life sure maybe I am
selfish maybe that is the you know what
this goes back to the Happ maybe I have
some insights I think your happiness com
from this this would be very interesting
so when Jack and I first started working
together it was 2020 he moved into the
guest house and was working all the time
I loved it because I had the same work
ethic and him and I would like 12 hours
a day seven days a week was amazing uh
but Jack I think after a year and I'm
speaking for you here and you could
chime in you said you weren't happy with
that and that you scaled back a lot you
started Outsourcing your work had a lot
more free time and I was like no pedal
to the metal we got to keep going keep
going keep I was like I can't do it I'm
not happy that's not me take I think
that people just get happiness from
different things and for me like I had
no friends i' had sacrificed my
friendships my relationships i'
sacrificed everything and for me it
wasn't worth it I wanted to be able to
go out and like sit in the Sun and get
some vitamin D or I wanted to go play
pickle ball and stuff like that but when
I was working so much even though I was
building my career and I'm so grateful
so grateful cuz I did work hard and I'm
happy I did but it was exhausting and I
wouldn't want to do that for the sure
maybe I maybe that is out of
selfishness look hey guys what do I know
you know I'm just trying to figure out
the thing too I'm just telling you what
I would do differently going back and
looking at later like dude I had this
time this this time between 25 and 35
that like I made so many mistakes in
those years okay all I did was work that
was a mistake but the pro the real
mistake was all I did was work on the
wrong [__] I was in the wrong lane wrong
opportunities around the wrong people I
had cleaned up my life between 25 and 35
and started putting some money together
and when I did I got around people that
said you don't need all this dude and
I'm like yeah you're right or you know
bigger is not better and then I stopped
I could have made so many moves back
then that would have me in a different
position later in my life that you don't
know about yet you say people should
invest in themselves right rather than
some form of like an ETF where you have
an expected return year-over-year yet
you provide something where people
invest for an expected return
year-over-year so how is that any
different than an ETF I'll tell you how
it's different okay number one the ETF
is liquid okay and you don't want to be
liquid okay you want to be IL liquid why
do you want to be IL liquid because you
don't want to have an emergency a
pothole or
pothead or both for you they goes and
gets that money okay that goes and gets
that money you're like oh my God I gotta
I got to sell my ETF dude long money is
made over long periods of time okay I
have never wanted to get rich quick ever
my entire life I'm like I don't want to
get rich quick I want to get rich Rich
for sure so my investment thesis is
about how do I get rich for sure well if
I'm Ill liquid which is what Wall Street
offers you my mama taught me this when I
was 18 or 19 years old if the casino
offers you something do not take it Wall
Street is a casino hey we want you to be
liquid man you can get your money
anytime you want they're not offering
that to you because it's good for you
they're offering it to you because it's
good for them I think the problem is
people sell is that people get emotional
but assuming you could but assuming you
could overcome that emotion and not
panic they can't bro they cannot so now
we're talking about real world right huh
so now we're talking about like the real
the real results of such a thing yeah in
my fund you are illiquid for 10 years
but you're but the benefit of being 6%
return with with with rents going up
every decade since you were born and
since I was born rents have gone up in
this country without missing a lick
every 10 years rents are going to go up
20 or 30% some doubled in many of those
decades okay while my debts being paid
down the rents are going up he knows the
real estate game this thing this this
mechanism inflation starts hitting Fiat
gets so you're saying that you're
protecting people from themselves
basically 100% and including myself by
the way I don't want the money why I go
to zero and I go hustle money again
wouldn't that then go against the idea
that they should become a business owner
because essentially you're protecting
them from themselves if you say you
should go get a high-paying job based
off of a marketable skill that you have
because that works if you look at real
results right whereas being a business
owner you're placing a lot of faith and
trust in people's ability when your fund
is the exact opposite you're not placing
faith and trust in people's ability to
make the best financial decision for no
no no my fund my fund I'm allowing
people to invest in assets they could
never
buy they can never buy these assets what
about a Reit they cannot buy these
assets most of the REITs do not control
the assets that we have okay and most of
the reats in this country are in trouble
right now can't hit their redemptions G
all the redemptions aren't making
distributions don't pick don't hand
select their properties they'll buy
anything and everything in almost any
Market with whatever the terms were
because they're churning money okay
these are big companies with thousands
of employees and are paying all these
analysts little fees if people followed
your advice then technically what they
should be doing is putting their money
and raising money from other people to
do what you're doing yeah they could and
we show people how to do that go go go
go raise $150 million to do that
deal I welcome like anybody to do it I
don't think they'd start it that long
Blackstone can't do it Blackstone can't
do it Fidelity can't do it they they you
know these are these are trillion dollar
companies and they can't go to Everyday
People because they ignored Everyday
People for the last 30 years and the the
big Banks this is really what I'm taking
on with card own Capital it's not just
the investment NE neither is the thesis
some of this stuff that I talk about it
is that the banks have control of the
way we think buy a house good for Bank
of America Fanny Ma's getting ready we
were talking about on the break Fanny
May's getting ready to offer a 5% down
on a 4unit deal
that'll happen November 18th it is going
to like the four unit product if you
live in it you can get a 5% loan with
Fanny
May I think for seven or 10 years okay
you're going to have people just just
flock to that asset
class doesn't mean it's good though just
going to sound good when the government
offers you
anything beware that's funny I get all
of these letters from Fanny May where
it's like oh you have equity in your
home maybe you should pull out some
money or refinance and stuff like that
I'm like yeah's refinancing right
they're offering me promotions like that
chances are it's not something that's
the best for me that's what I'm telling
you man like do you think like why do
people think banks in this country are
so safe when they're not well we've been
trained we've been trained to believe
they're safe okay there's been more bank
failures I think people have faith in
the government that no matter what
what'll happen with a bank the
government will step in they'll never
let things go that bad like they're too
big to fail just SE they seek to in that
conversation they seek to drop out that
little piece of data that says in my
lifetime the 100 Grand that I left at
that bank is worth
$10,000 it's safe yeah it's safe to go
down and value it's not invested if it's
at the bank it's not invested the bank
the same bank you put your money in as
you know calls me and says would you
like to borrow their money they don't
leave it
there I think the point of a bank is
more so just everyday expenses I got to
have something I got to have money
liquid right yeah back toid in terms of
in terms of teaching people how do you
find a good Mentor and what do you look
for how do you make sure that they're
not like a fake Guru or they're giving
bad advice show me what you got bro you
you build wood tables and you're going
to do videos on wood tables okay well
show me the wood tables that you built
show me the factory that you have show
me your inventory show me don't tell me
I am no not like this is how I avoid
getting ripped off and one thing I've
done extremely well in my life is not
get ripped off of but don't you feel
like especially on Instagram people Flex
all the time and they have all the all
the stuff in their pictures but like how
do you verify owners show me that plane
I saw a kid the other day I'm like is
that your plane no it's not your plane
it's a Phenom 300 I know exactly who who
whose plane it is it's not yours you're
in the shadow taking a video of yourself
you didn't even get permission to take
the video of yourself in front of that
plane or on the side of the plane so
people just should be very suspect like
anybody that checks me out hey come
check out what I own like do an audit on
my business because I'm not worried
about what you find the FBI the SEC
every threel company group in America
has all the data they need on me so why
wouldn't I tell
you okay I got my seven rings that makes
sense I think like a that's what people
should do show don't tell top of the
food chain all the instagrammers all the
YouTubers all the names that you've
mentioned everybody show me right you're
a real estate expert show me the real
estate you bought okay you're a Bitcoin
Guy this is where the Bitcoin Community
goes nuts I'm listening to a Bitcoin guy
the other night in X spaces and BT I
said how much Bitcoin you got bro I
can't tell you that I said then shut the
[__] up it's all like when the nfts were
popularized everyone's like I'm an nft
expert an AI expert oh as soon as chat
PT comes out everyone's like oh I'm an
we someone and like show me the book you
wrote right right not not the [__]
paragraph not the three questions you
asked I would say that's a good way to
filter through just show me because the
moment most people are going to do this
why do you need all this why do you have
to have all this data particularly the
mentor community so the the the problem
is with the people that want
help can become
targets you know and be taken advantage
of I need help I need help everybody
does by the way I needed help when I was
16 years old and a drug dealer got hold
of me I'll help you bro and took me down
a nasty road so that was my first
experience with mentors right now it's
like okay I need to pick people that I
want to be like oh the guy's Rich okay
good what's his family life look like
what does he look like as a father what
does he look like even the books I read
you know before I go buy somebody's book
and read their [__] I'm like
hey who are they oh he committed suicide
when he was you know 57 I'm [__] I ain't
reading this
yet you don't think but you don't you
don't think there's something you could
learn from that person I don't care I
don't want to learn from that guy what
about you learn what not to do you know
what I mean like I feel like you bro why
are you learning [__] died kill
why do I want to study a cat that
freaking Tapped Out All I know is
whatever he was doing he was so [__]
miserable with himself that he killed
himself I got the whole world trying to
kill me but I think there are such
talented great minds out
there but have been suffering from
severe mental illness or depression but
their thoughts are are genius brilliant
couldn't you learn bits and pieces and
exclude push out no I want to go read
I'm going to go find the guy that didn't
didn't terminate even if that person's
knowledge what's the name guy's name
that had the hit TV show who is this
Anthony Bourdain yeah I ain't studying
[__] he did okay what's the comedian's
name that Tapped Out Robin Williams [__]
him I ain't studying none of this [__]
because it didn't work but if you want
to be a comedian and you want to you
know what I mean no I'm going to study
Kevin har I'm going to study Kevin har
I'm study Dave Chappelle but there could
be aspects of their life that work so
well and then other aspects that just
don't and you could study the aspects
that work comedy if I'm studying his
comedy his Pace his way to write a joke
yeah cool but I'm not going to study him
as a he's my mentor for life that's what
I'm saying I tend to think that in
everybody you could find bits and pieces
that you agree with you time I I want to
read about the winners man but you don't
think that they won in certain aspects
but if I can't read every book written I
can't study I can't have that many
mentors but then they could be great at
like like you know could still yeah I'm
I'm to study a great YouTuber do I study
you or Mr Beast I would say Mr Beast
absolutely we agree on that completely
okay I'm not going to study both of you
I'm gonna study him and I'm gonna go
hard on that one guy and I'm not going
to take hypothetically hypothetically
yeah Mr Beast unives himself a year from
now would that mean that everything you
learned from Mr Beast doesn't apply
anymore stud him about life I wasn't
getting father advice from him I'm
saying if I'm going to get the father
advice I need to see the kids and how
they're doing right now I would take you
YouTube advice from him because I'm like
[__] his YouTube channel rocks okay
and if I have a choice between his
channel and your channel I'm taking his
channel and I'm not going to study two
people I'm going hard with one guy okay
now before I take his advice on how to
be
fit I ain't going to do it I could see
the way he's not fit like that's not my
FIT advice right I'm going to go to
somebody that can what is something you
need help with dude I need help with a
million things I got 99
problems um
well I mean we're scaling a bunch of
businesses out right now like where do
you want to go here uh I think
personally would would be really
interesting just for yourself whether
that be heal I get a lot I get a lot of
help personally so so I'm not asking you
guys for personal help because I go to
my church for that yeah so anytime I
have like spiritually I'm a little lost
or confused or I'm making poor decisions
I know exactly where to go I'm going
Route myself to my church spend a week
there two weeks there get it all routed
out come back out and attack the world
how did you get involved in the church
where did where did you find that outlet
I read the book dynetics somebody gave
it to me when I was 25 years old I was
just out a treatment center it helped me
understand why I had you turned to drugs
it was phenomenal you could you explain
well it's in the book could you explain
because we don't know anything about it
yeah I mean if you want to learn about
it it's in the book but but basically
the book The the book D next is about a
reactive mind it's about a mind that
reacts rather than being
analytical so for me I want to be more
analytical than reactive even though I
am
quite I I I I tend to be a bit re I can
be reactive right I don't mind fighting
I don't mind you know getting angry I
don't mind pushing back but I don't want
to do that most of the time most of the
time I just want to be analytical hey I
have this much time I could do this I
want to calc everything's a calculation
the more analytical a person could be
the better decisions they're going to
make Yeah the more reactive oh this
feels good let's do this let's sleep
together you end up with herpes like
that right you're you're emotional you
know oh let's have a drink the drink
leads to the weed the weed leads to the
we that's emotional decision-making
right so this book is about the reactive
mind and how the mind acts operates
reactively it responds and reacts not in
a good way so it's like stoicism I don't
know what stoicism is it's similar to
that like the fundamental belief of
stoicism is like okay I burnt my finger
once and now I think all fire is unsafe
this is what I'm talking about reactive
a equals a that happened I can't never
do it again okay somebody RI me off I
can never I can never be never going to
do business again I hired somebody uh
and they quit or they betrayed me I'm
never hiring another person I I went out
with this girl she's a blonde and now I
can't trust all blonds or freak that's
reactive yeah yeah stoicism is it sounds
similar because stoicism the whole idea
is that you insert a gap between your
resp your reaction and your response
definitely definitely not definitely not
definitely not analytical is 1 plus 1
equals 2 okay I can trust that answer
okay you're offing to some other Buddha
Buddha okay let's he keep going so so
anyway when I read this book I'm like
dude this explains why I had a drug
addiction now the people at the
Narcotics Anonymous in the rehab were
telling me I had a I had an addiction
that I had a disease and that I was
always going to be powerless and this
book's like no no bro okay and so that
book helped me a lot and now I wouldn't
start actually studying Scientology for
another 20 years and I've been studying
it now for 20 21 years it's been
phenomenal for my personal life and
that's all I want to say about I'm not I
don't promote the church I don't work
chur there does seem to be this
correlation overall that there are some
very successful people who are into
Scientology why more than you know my
friend more than you know it's not just
Tom and John and Grant have you ever met
Tom Cruz yes I have really at a
Scientology event uh I've met him
outside that actually first time I met
him was at the burback airport did you
connect with him over Scientology no no
I connect he knew who I was really yeah
do but you don't talk I was with I was
with who was I with the other day I was
with the mayor of not the mayor the
governor
uh what's his name Nome I was at the
Beverly Hills at a Michael milin uh
event I'm sitting in this chair right
here uh Nome sitting right where Sabrina
is he moves comes and sits right next to
me and says bro nobody works harder than
you do he's like I cannot get away from
you on instant said this yeah and then
he throws you an audit like right
after exactly oh by the way yeah I said
bro I cuz I'm not a fan right but I
don't want to say anything yeah and I'm
like how do you how do you R how do you
like handle an entire State man people
every day coming up with bad ideas
telling you do this do that like it I
got respect for a guy that can do that
but the fact that Tom knows me or he
knows me or Chappelle or it's because
I've been on social man I use the social
platforms to get to get attention these
guys are not going to hit the follow
button just so you know some of your
best audience will never hit follow and
will never comment but they're watching
but in terms of Scientology why does it
seem like so many people are successful
within that maybe the technology there
Works what is it what technology like
what what is it you should grab a book
dude anything you want like
communication skills it teach you how to
communicate teaches you how to raise
children teach you how to have a
marriage it teaches you uh how to how to
have conditions in life and go from
average that word you use multiple times
and normal to like okay I want to create
power in my life or affluence it allows
you there's courses there about how to
pick people how to ask good questions to
be sure people you know I don't know if
you guys have ever been a liability in
your life I know I have and I know other
people in my life that were friends and
assets that became liabilities how can
you spot those people yeah right their
courses this is not a this is not a
religion where you pray to a god right
this is not where there's a dogma and
you go to church on Sundays hit a knee
and sign of the cross or whatever I'm
not all I think all religions are
valuable in in part and personally but
this particular religion teaches
somebody practically how to make their
life better through knowing how life
responds to the decisions that you make
that makes so that's why it's called
Scientology yeah it means knowing how to
know thank you Scientology means knowing
how to know how do I know so why is
there such a negative connotation
amongst the general public you ever
studied religions no not really yeah
there's a negative connotation on every
religion since the beginning I agree but
I think that they they're to varying
degrees no they're they're all bro you
you you got two people over there
fighting in the desert right now over a
religion mhm you got they killed Jesus
Christ like this is not a new thing okay
new ideas are resisted first they're
resisted then they're criticized then
they're adopted and then later they're
like hey that's the thing we so you
think because it's a new idea it's just
being met with resistance such as all
other new ideas 100% and it also these
new ideas and this technology replaces
some of the offerings being made to
society today like drugs MH so like yeah
what are some of the teachings when it
comes to picking a person being a good
father being a good role model like what
are some of the the fundamental belief
fundamental beliefs on that you mean my
beliefs well the beliefs that would you
would learn from you would subscribe to
from
Scientology I
mean I I I don't know I I I don't know
if another Scientologist would agree
with this like it's not I'm not adopting
their beliefs I have my own beliefs so a
discovery your s of what's right for me
like if you've ever met is that a virtue
of
Scientology is to figure out what
certainly helped me it's like like what
I said it's it's helped me in life be a
better father for sure be a better
parent but that's not because I read
something said oh that's what I ascribe
to I I get you know I analytically get
to choose why would I want my kids out
of the school system okay and then say
oh [__] that's going to be hard to do
man I got a home school oh my God the
responsibility is enormous so no dude I
want him out of the school system cuz I
don't want them in the school system
with teachers that are
unhappy with principls that are unhappy
with the other kids that are unhappy and
with the the parents of the other kids
that are unhappy okay so I think I
understand so Scientology doesn't
necessarily show you exactly how to
navigate a given circumstance it just
instills that idea or value that you
should always fall back on your thinking
or analytical brain to then make
decisions in the future not necessarily
like this is how you become a good
communicator follow the things there are
some courses that can actually teach you
what communication means okay most
people think communication is just other
more subjective things like being a good
you know father teacher or something
like that like it's more so just like
study based off of your own experiences
and then act accordingly and don't be
resistant towards maybe some critiques
and stuff like that I mean I look it's a
it's a massive massive volume of of
information you're not going to get it
in this podcast and and I'm not the guy
to get it from look I'm just a I'm just
a parisher I'm just a guy that's
benefited from it every area of my life
is better because of it that's all I
know so anybody that's interested in it
or to go grab a book there's a book
called problems of work phenomenal book
on happiness and work and productivity
how to be more productive as a human
being there's communication courses most
of these courses are free online you can
literally go do an online course for
free on how to have a relationship which
most people suck at yeah how do you have
a relationship well the seems like you
have a great family your daughter seems
like quite quite the r or die she's
fantastic uh she she rolls with me a lot
of places and they've been homeschooled
for you know we took them out of the
system for about six years ago right six
walk us through that decision six years
ago to remove both of your children
Elena and I Elena is a phenomenal
partner and and uh we went to her school
country what dat Miami Country Day Miami
Country
Day and was $226,000 a kid okay they're
good you know that's what we're thinking
we go over there one day and we're I'm
like this isn't good what about it the
other kids what was wrong with the kids
and everything they're not what I want
my kids to be like what were they doing
they look scared they look you know like
what they what they're learning I'm like
where's the confidence in these kids man
where's the freaking happiness where's
the the the the running and the like
what are they learning let me see the
books they're learning from I'm like I
don't want to do this I didn't want to
do it when I went to school did you guys
like school no did you like it the
education part not necessarily I'm like
I'm not doing this to these kids this is
this is ridiculous why do we keep doing
this thing when we know it's not getting
good products so we pulled them out of
the school system elen and I decided
okay we're going to be responsible for
their education we're going to get a
nanny we're going to get somebody to
help and support them and I know a lot
of people can't afford to do all that
but I couldn't afford personally cost me
a lot to do this because we have to put
attention we had to re kind of redo our
lives it's easier just to drop them off
someplace I'm not talking about money
right now and immediately man within two
weeks we saw a change in them they were
happier we were able to spend more time
with them it was really for us to spend
more time we were traveling yeah school
system told me I couldn't take the kids
out for three weeks to go on a we were
going to do a 19 uh Country tour and
they couldn't leave otherwise they would
fail I'm like I ain't doing this yet I
want control of my kids and they got
better who's educating your daughters
how how does it work sabran you you we
she could she could hop in if you're
comfortable yeah jump in blood jump in
little blood we could always pull up
another chair actually you want to pull
up a chair here yeah yeah let me get
your chair hold on okay so we're
homeschooled through an online program
and with this online program I get um
you know a different course each year
and within that course there's
subdivisions you know math English
biology um etc etc and with that program
you have all the lessons all um the
books everything you need to know
everything you need to complete to
finish the grade okay so I go through
that and every year I finish each
course um sorry now you're good I finish
each course usually way ahead of uh
normal school so last year I finished
n9th grade in five months but who's
educating you you know I'm kind of I'm
kind of educating myself the program is
educating uh me like do you have a
teacher I have a tutor so with the tutor
uh you know we do calls and he kind of
like helps me um if there's anything I'm
struggling with anything I don't quite
understand so it helps me get caught up
but with the program it has like um um
like videos the same way you would um
learn from a teacher it teaches you what
it is in very simple terms do a week um
maybe 10 10 hours so I agree that's the
thing it's like actual learning you
don't need more than that right I I do
think that people need to learn from
videos more than they do from
teachers everyone learns at different
speeds I'm C is there anything you
missed from school like friends like
your dad was saying you didn't like the
people that were with you at school
didn't like yeah okay you know I I never
like I never liked any of my peers when
I went to school okay you didn't like
them at all no I hated them what did you
hate about them was
it sorry I didn't say
that yeah she did that's I'm sorry her
words not mine man I didn't hate them I
didn't hate them not to be dramatic um I
I didn't connect to them I've never
connected with people my age I've never
felt like they really understood me I've
never formed close relationships with
anyone really my age all my close
friends are a good two or three years
older than me um do you think that's
because you've traveled so much with
your dad and you've seen what he's done
and been around him enough that it kind
of makes you grow up faster you know
maybe maybe but um like I would say like
today my dad's my best friend my dad and
my mom like I have a fantastic
relationship with my parents like I feel
like I can come to them for like
anything and I'm not just saying that
like
genuinely um gas him up man gas no like
genuinely and you know I I've done stuff
more recently like I've done summer
courses and all this stuff to like try
to see like do I like the environment
with other kids I've just never
connected to it it's never really been
my you don't have any interests that are
like I would say like more normal or
average sorry to use that famous word
again every time you say you're be I
know I'm just curious because like you
know when I was 14 I had different
interest than I have right now yeah I
mean I do like I do sports like I do uh
running I've done a Varity of different
running programs like that's a fun way
to talk to oh I did rowing once yeah
that was horseback riding horse I did
horseback riding for a time yeah I'm
pretty good um so I I've connected great
real estate I am great at real estate
it's a very fun hobby of
mine so you know I have like some
different interests but um that I like
to take up in my free time but um you
know it's it's more for me it's just I I
like producing like I genuinely do like
producing things I like running okay can
we PR this um this 5K today you know so
okay so I I asked her that because
remember how earlier in the conversation
I asked what do you want out of your
daughter do you want happiness and you
said no you want productivity yeah and I
asked them I'm like well as a daughter
you know what I mean like if someone
asked my dad what do you want out of
your son and he was like ah productivity
and he did well sorry not to but he said
like not happiness I'll would be like oh
you know like part of me would kind of I
I would say hurt for that the problem
with you know not the way I was raised
because I we didn't have any money but
with the way she's raised there's you
know there's money she doesn't she never
wants for anything everything's handled
right so now the problem with that
is she she grows up in an environment
where first of all other kids are going
to later accuse her her being a rich kid
and number two that she could naturally
take it you know take for granted oh I
have a jet well no she doesn't have a
jet I have a jet she gets to ride on my
jet okay she could take that for granted
I mean that would be easy to happen so
that's why I'm telling you if when she
leaves this thing and all of a sudden
hits the world and she can't do anything
that's a problem it'd be a problem for
her right so what I want to do is with
the homeschooling should get her out of
the school system so that she can start
being more productive in the real world
and having experiences like this one
right here yeah you there's no reason
all kids should not be able to do what
she is doing at 14 years old on that mic
right now do you worry that maybe not
having some of those experiences that
you went through might mean that there
are some situations that you're less
prepared for I'm not saying like drugs
or anything like that but I'm saying
that having nothing like absolutely
nothing and having to work your way up
from that fair it's a fair it's a fair
yeah so but what what do I do I shove
her out there and say hey go learn it
this way if my dad if my dad had not
died my brother and I were talking about
this the other day today I don't think I
would be who I am today him not being
there I'm not talking about all the bad
years I'm not talking about the drug
addiction that didn't make me who I am
going down 10 years wasting all that 10
years that did not make me who I am but
not having a dad and watching my Mom
struggle started making me make
decisions like this whole home thing
probably why I don't think a home is a
good deal it's CU I saw my mom having to
sell the house as soon as he died
because she could no longer to maintain
it so dude I I mean I don't I I just
want to give her the you
know quick start in the world that she
can like at least communicate to you
what about the bar what about the bar
being set so high like do you ever look
at your dad and think how do I live up
to that or exceed that expectation I
mean that's definitely there like I
don't want to like I like it would be I
would feel so ashamed of myself if I did
not if if I didn't do anything you know
I had this opportunity I could have done
something and if I if I like at the end
of my life didn't do anything I will
feel so ashamed of myself and you know
maybe you know maybe that's not a good
thing but I think that it is because
it's going to force me um it's going to
force me in my life to do something but
who's deciding what anything is is that
you or is that your father or is that
Society I ever told you what to do no so
what if like but it seems like you're
anything is very similar to his anything
right he's a role model for me I grew up
I he's a role model for me you know mhm
that makes sense he's an influence that
makes sense to me mhm and
um three what is you got to keep going
like of course of course my ideas of
what my future should look like is going
to be reflected in him of course
obviously I mean
um like he's my main where I get what I
how about this where are your
differences because I'm sure you have a
lot of similarities but where do you not
see eye to eye with your dad some of his
ideas like here we go all of them like
sometimes I'm like you know I don't know
how I feel about that like and I'll talk
to him about it sometimes we'll have
like these little debates in the car he
thinks I'm arguing sometimes he's like
Sabrina why do you keep arguing with me
I'm like I'm not arguing with you I'm
just trying to talk to you um you know
we don't always see eye to eye on
everything but uh we're like give him
something yeah yeah we want we want some
examples would you get free pass right
now you can say anything you want to
I'll give you an example like like I hit
people really I hit people really hard
like when somebody comes at me dude I
hit back like like that reporter video
everybody including my wife my co uh
Jared the president of the company like
man don't do that video Everybody for
context Explain real quick this I took
this guy on online called him out you
were talking about it I don't know if
that's helps you or hurts you you know
that's their whole conversation about
whether you even defend yourself so I
get a lot of that she hears me hit
people say I don't know that might have
been too much I mean I I let that piece
of paper go out the window the other day
oh oh my God she he littered he littered
that's that's a big no no I don't like
that huge and it wasn't a big deal for
me I'm like dude what do you mean so
what what was the situation it was a
piece of Pap it was a straw yeah oh was
straw those were the one thing I give up
paper straw bro paper straw paper straws
could be okay it was the wrapping of a
straw oh yeah plastic plas plastic and I
was very disappointed I could not
believe that he threw that out the
window I didn't throw it he threw it the
wind pulled it off my thing but did did
you have it out and then yeah okay okay
so yeah know but that is one thing like
sometimes he's a little I'm just like
man why do you have to be so aggressive
with that person but hey look it gets
the job done so is there anything that
you've wanted to do that you've said no
you can't do that a few a few something
like going out in public like like
without okay like um this a this a big
issue it's a big issue for us so um I
like running right right how I told you
um he doesn't want me to run by myself
you know I'm he he wants kind I get Mak
get it 100% like I honestly do agree and
I even got them to a point where I
convinced them to let me go by myself
and not have someone following me cuz
it's kind of embarrassing to have
somebody follow you while you run what
if you want to stop you can't stop you
have somebody right they're going to
judge you I didn't know about
that got a timer they're like oh you
didn't make your time I'm like guys
please yeah um I even got them to that
point but then this young girl came to
my house and she was like I saw you on
your runs let's become friends and I was
like okay who saw you just a random
random girl she's like I've seen you out
on runs I'm like okay well maybe uh we
should go back I understand I
get yeah take no I I I do that's the
part that makes it so hard for me I
agree with him but I don't like it would
you say would you say he's
overprotective as a father or you you
think the right amount you know the the
daughter in me wants to say he's
overprotective but the person in me
wants to say he's the right amount you
know like the analytical human being
wants to say that he's the right amount
of overprotective yeah like you know
they're they're actually both my parents
are pretty pretty like relaxed you'd be
surprised really like they let me like
hang out with my friends they like me
like I have social media and stuff like
I know people who don't have social
media do you regulate her social media
at all really no we we uh the one thing
we had it was younger it was probably
four or five years ago and I went to her
and I said her mom actually came to me
and said I think there's a problem with
the social I'm the better person to tell
her than her mom is I just it's easier
it's a different flow different kind of
vibe right so there's always one parent
that can you know do something she Elena
can do better at certain things and then
and we just got to know our little spots
yeah and so I went to her and I'm like
hey um I want to look at your your the
channels you have the apps you have okay
and I want you to tell me
you must have been eight or nine at the
time yeah tell me which one of these are
good for
you she started
looking this one this one maybe not you
know I said okay okay what how do you
feel about YouTube oh no that step
Graham's been popping up he's that guy's
definitely suspect okay that guy I don't
know about YouTube anymore because of
him okay and then and she'd see Tik Tock
oh that one's definitely bad that one
and then I'm like okay what do you want
to do with them next thing you know
she's like I'm a delete that I'mma
delete I'mma delete YouTube because of
Graham and and and and and and I never
want to see his face again that's fair
and Instagram I'm gonna keep that I
think I can keep that open but it was up
to her not
me yeah and if if I did that the way I
grew up dude it'd be like give me your
phone right I would take the phone and I
would decide everything for them rather
than giving them at 8 six seven eight
years old and you can decide you know
but do you do you worry about getting
like waves of hate or criticism directed
it like if I couldn't handle that at 14
yeah and like you're coming into this
you might not's doing right now that's
probably true yeah but I'm trying to
think how that would affect me at that
age versus now where it's been like a
very slow buildup and you kind of build
that you know you haven't been hit with
the hate yet okay I remember the TC that
you talked about earlier my wife and
I met with him and he says and Elena's
like Grant Grant's getting so much heat
online you know and he just cracks up
laughing just laughing he's like excuse
me I mean this guy has gotten taken on
as much hate as a human being can take
online so it's like you're going to get
it you know you're just going to it's
going to all come at one time
something's going to happen people are
going to turn on you you know yeah it'll
happen how do you internalize that at
your age not to take it personally and
to just expect that hey some people are
going to say things
some of it used to make me like a little
bit upset but never when it was about me
like ever because like I've seen stuff
like people have said like things like
about how I look I'm like stupid like
just shut up like it doesn't even matter
I'm 14 like the fact that you're
commenting on a 14-year-old appearance
is okay that's a mature stance okay
whenever it actually made me upset was
like when it was about my dad but then I
started seeing the most
ridiculous far off stuff and I was like
okay if this is lies then all of it must
be lies yeah I have a question regarding
preno UPS because your wife didn't want
one correct uhhuh I remember I saw her
speak somewhere and she went on this
whole spiel about you wanted a prenup
and she says nope I'm not getting a prup
we're not getting married the only way
we're getting married no prup mhm and
then you said okay yeah that's true why
why did you agree at that time for no
prenup you wanted one initially yeah I
you know look I mean we'll play this out
I later I'll find out whether this was
the right thing to do or not you know um
but
but I don't think that's a problem right
the the issue is not the prenup the
issue is how am I going to live with
another human being every day how am I
going to get along how am I going to
create you know how do I create when
you're new in the marriage at 40 how do
you create when you're 50 how do you
create when you're 60 how do you create
in in the later supposedly the golden
years to make them golden a lot of
things in my life are still to be played
out and that that could be one of them
that could be one of the most expensive
decisions I ever made in my life what
would you say to your daughter let's
assume you're getri defitely get a prup
that's what I was about to say what but
what if
love but it's the love of her life and
he says I don't want to prup I'm not
getting married I would tell her she
will absolutely get a
prenup
1,000% or she will never get she will
never get access to my my whatever
my bucket is how was your wife different
in that scenario with you and her I
don't know and and I don't want to turn
this into to to a troll kind of
clickbait thing but uh as much as you'll
be tempted um but I think we would both
look at it different today you know you
know I was we we never dreamed our we
would be where we're at right now we
have there's four or five billion dollar
for the real estate there's the the 11
companies that are probably worth three
or four billion I never dude I never
thought ever in my life lifetime we
would be where we're at but we are and
she she has
participated despite the fact that she's
not in the office doing X Y and Z and I
am she has participated in many ways um
beyond what I would have ever asked a
wife to do for me she she has been a
phenomenal partner for me and I hope
this is never used in a in in in a court
of law against me but but I mean in a
deposition I would have to say yeah dude
she participated
now now I would not just for
that let's say there was a divorce okay
and she's like I want half I'm like dude
that's not fair right she didn't
participate 5050 you did unbelievable I
don't even know how to measure what
she's done the support never yet nag
nagging on me never not one time in in
20 years saying oh you work too hard
never not one time like rare arguments
about anything like she's been a
phenomenal partner uh child birth these
two guys without drugs at home without
us bringing them to hospital she's a
[__] Warrior Man okay so all that
being said it still ain't worth
half I just wanted that for the
deposition how do you balance running a
business and having such a happy
marriage it's hard man that that's a
very difficult thing to do it's very
difficult I'm in I'm because I'm in the
I'm in the I'm in the war every day
right I'm in the I mean it is a to me
every day is
like is a battle I'm not this is not I'm
not coasting yeah you know I'm not I'm
not a coaster here I'm like I'm I'm
uphill most the time most of my days are
fours on a scale to 10 uh today would
probably be like a three since I spent
so much time with you guys but um
especially this guy um but but rarely do
I have eight or a nine day so I'm going
home most of the time beat up Hammer
didn't get what I wanted lost and then I
go I got I got to be somebody else when
when I get home and I'm not great at
that right cuz I'm still dragging that
with me so it's just it's it's a bit of
a lot of communication yeah what's your
advice to me I'm getting married next
year yeah just get a get an agreement
not just the not the prenups not the
important thing it I mean I guess it
could be but but more importantly what
what what I would say is make sure that
person is ready to go on the same ride
you're you're you're you want to go on
and that your
ride might actually be bigger than you
even know today if the if the past 33
years of your life is
anything like the next 33 is like the
last 33 you've underestimated everything
you would do and did not predict most of
the great things that you would do
including what we're doing today sure
even six years ago you didn't think we'd
be doing this definitely now we're doing
it so when you were six years old you
never imagin you'd be in a room with all
this gear so you have underestimated
you've actually missed mess
mispredicted all the things all your
potential you'll do the same thing
you'll look up later and say goddamn
dude I had no idea I had this much
potential much like a little kid does
when he's riding a bike for the first
time he can never imagine that he's
going to be you know popping Willies
riding a motorcycle one day because he's
so overwhelmed by this one piece of
Machinery so that's what I do just make
sure she's on the same page for the
whole ride bro sure you know and that's
what I got from Elena I said look I'll
give you anything except one thing I
will not not ever compromise my
dreams and I like to work I like to
produce don't ever ask me not to this is
my little this the thing I want to do
and she's she never
asked and don't spend a bunch of money
on your wedding yeah no we're not
spending that much stupid yeah you know
yeah I think we're going to be Allin
under 15 grand yeah that's fantastic
brilliant brilliant probably going to
turn to 20 but yeah maybe 25 you
bringing him yeah he's officiating oh
yeah what does that mean I get to like
you read the whole thing yeah ohes he
said and then we say I do oh cool you're
Minister just apply online 20 bucks take
mebody do online Minister easy easy
where you going to do the wedding uh
we're between two places one is a winery
that we picked out and another is a
friend's house okay and so the house
would be a lot easier it's a really nice
place and we we could have it basically
the whole weekends it's simple but the
winery looks a little nicer for photos
so yeah yeah is there anything you're
you're fearful of when it comes to your
daughter in terms of like just growing
up or entering the real world or yeah a
lot of things man I worry about her and
Scarlet more than any anything you know
the first their liabilities for me right
because I worry about somebody taking
them you know I remember watching people
get really successful and then they had
to have security around them I'm like
dude that's got to be terrible and then
one day I'm like oh I got to have
security you know not for me like me I'm
not worried about me I'm worried about
her
so that that concerns me too is um the
world out there dude it's like it's she
went to what was that school you went to
I went to Oxford for a summer camp yeah
you think it's going to be a great
school right she's calling me the first
day saying hey these people are crazy
what was what was wrong with it there
was this one guy okay weed Vape um all
that kind of stuff was all the kids were
like just having it like it was two
weeks okay people were like doing stuff
with each other like sneak out and like
going to each other's rooms Oxford as in
like Oxford College Oxford College how
how old were the people there yeah so
everyone's old right 13 to 16 oh 13 to
16 oh wow okay it was insane it was
insane it was not the experience that I
wanted it was not the experience that I
was expecting uh I went there to study
politics and international relations I
did not learn very much from that course
that being said I did learn a little bit
but we we went we did classes like two
hours a day four days a week
it's nothing you know um how much was it
what did I pay for that eight grand or
something more than that like God like
like maybe too much too much they didn't
feed us very well um but that that being
said it was like kind of a good
experience for me I kind of enjoyed it
it was like fun to like live on my own I
didn't like anyone there though but tell
them tell them on the two days before
you
ended right before it ended I called you
and said ask all the kids if they think
it was worth what they parents paid oh
nobody nobody agreed that that camp was
worth it not a single kid not the ones
who were selling weed and vape why did
they disagree cuz the education was poor
because the education was horrible and
there was no there was no control in
that school and the counselors knew what
was happening but they were like okay if
we don't catch you it doesn't matter
they said that to us headline this they
said to
us if we don't catch you you can do
whatever you want you know the kids they
loved being wild and like free and doing
whatever they want but they did not
agree that it was worth their parents
money and they thought it was a waste
and none of them or at least like 90% of
them are not going to go back next year
so I mean it was it was a waste of money
and probably a waste of time but um you
know experience is there any part of you
that wants to have that sort of teenage
experience there is no part of me that I
I I do not believe that I would enjoy
that I've never been the kind of person
who's liked to go to parties I've never
liked to and this actually reminds me of
a good point that school that I was
going to Miami Country Day one of the
best schools in Miami you know Shakira's
kids go there I think jla's kids I think
go there I'm not sure um I know
Shakira's kids go there um and it is
known by the alumni of the school and it
is known by people my age who are aware
of the schools in Miami that that school
is a very druggy school there's a lot of
drugs a lot of alcohol um like
especially when it gets up to like high
school and stuff um and there's there's
also like a lot of rampant bullying
there it's the weirdest thing you
wouldn't think you wouldn't think you
know you think nice school okay they're
going to keep it control they're going
to keep regulated keep the kids in line
no kids do whatever they want I'm I
really like to be in control I really
like to be at like cause point of
whatever I do I don't think any part of
me would like to go drinking or to do
drugs and I've never done any of that
kind of stuff um and I have no interest
in ever trying it to be honest what do
you want to do in life yeah you know I'm
not quite sure what I want to do I know
I definitely like am interested in real
estate and I do want to at this point um
do what my dad's doing and help him with
that and maybe eventually take it over
one day um you know I had a Little Dream
to run away to West Virginia randomly
why West Virginia I don't know I think I
read it in a book just I think I read
about in a book and um open an ice cream
shop and sell ice cream but I I realize
now that that's not only unrealistic but
also why would I do that ice cream could
be a big business though ice cream could
be very fun open a franch I could be
like the next V in Jerry's yeah true
yeah know ice cream would be very fun
and I've always had a lot of like ice
cream I don't even really like ice cream
so I don't know oh okay yeah I don't
know where that where that came from but
I but do you still think about it ever
or no no not at all no it was a it was a
two- Monon thing don't know what was up
with that she getting ready to get a car
though that's a big oh yeah I am getting
ready to get a car oh what's the car uh
we we're well I'm trying to sell it to
them if it was a vintage Bronco dude she
would be over a vintage Bronco the deal
the ones without airbags yes yeah but no
doors on the side no roof so look I
don't want it to be like a super nice
car I don't want it to be like a snobby
car I just want it to be something I can
get around in but I also don't want it
to be like end of the line like horrible
like should not even be driven kind of
car because like you know our family
does have money and I do feel like I um
do like help and exchange with my
parents and I feel like having like a
mid-range Car Sales is coming I'm
waiting I'm waiting for the a mid-range
car would be
appropriate midrange car but but but the
point here is she the thing she worries
about more is like if she got something
really nice she's like do not give me
something really nice I want something a
little bit um give us like some give us
give us yeah some cars like the perfect
car a realistic car and CRV something
like a new you know on the CRV maybe
something safe I want definitely not a
sedan um I don't like being low to the
ground okay um also like accidents you
can get injured a lot more easily also
I'm not planning on getting in any
accidents so I could get I'm going to
say an Audi q6 actually I have been told
that I have been told that Audi Q I have
yeah um well we'll see we'll see what
kind what kind of car should I get get
what kind of car should I get let me
know I'm trying to say it to them as
like a family car Alexis like a SUV
Alexis SUV is a great car but no I'm
curious about like running alone and
driving alone couldn't there also be
someone like just like tailing a car or
something like that like where do you
draw the line at that point I mean look
at some point some point we just got to
you know I mean can't always be with
them some point it's just paranoia no no
nobody's going to do anything she knows
how to protect herself we're doing
another class this year so um
you know yeah there's other things that
can be done so do you have a car picked
out like no no not yet no okay um no but
I'm really excited she's been driving
since she was like 12 have you really
yeah um like in parking lots and like
with our cars and stuff and once down
the PCH are you serious no yes I am
serious sorry I am serious I'm not
kiding are you not are you not nervous
of just like down PCH there's a lot of
cars a lot of traffick bicyclist really
early in the morning so nobody was
really out yet and um what car was it
escal an escalator oh yeah a big car
okay yeah so it was fun it was a very
fun expence like some of this like when
we were kids when I was a kid if you
lived on a farm you'd be driving by now
like a lot of these rules and
regulations are just they're stying kids
to even experience life right so like
she can communicate we when we were
raising her we we were like hey there's
no strangers in our life okay like you
meet you can meet everybody
now you have to also keep two eyes open
for bad people like there's bad people
you have to keep but most people are not
bad people and most people are not
strangers or below you or above you they
are people that you should communicate
with and be excited about meeting and
get to know and introduce yourself and
have a conversation with but you have to
have two eyes open for somebody that has
bad intentions and maybe is evil or
unconscious how do you spot that well
there's courses on it how how to do that
but but for the average person who's
watching this right now and they're just
like what can I look for what's a
Telltale sign you know like knowing this
yeah trust your knowingness trust what
you know you know you don't feel good so
intuition yeah and how how's this person
what time of day is it you know if I'm
meeting you at 2 o'clock in the
afternoon it's different than if I'm
meeting you at 2 o'clock in the morning
so keep yourself out of situations that
are dangerous Jamie Fox invited me to a
birthday party he had once and I said
okay guys when when is it and they said
3 o'clock in the morning I'm like I
ain't going to that you know and they're
like why not I said' because this is at
3:00 in the morning nothing good happens
at 3:00 in the morning so um that's
people need to make sure they're in a
good Strong place before I'm worried
about you I need to worry about me make
sure I know I'm aware I'm conscious I'm
not drunk I'm not smoking weed that I
can make good good decisions sure have
you ever heard of like
hypomania no so it's a term that Tai
Lopez says your favorite person Tai Tai
I call him Tai Tai tie tie he'll like
that I bet and uh it describes someone
who has like excess levels or excessive
levels of energy and like early in the
morning they're like right out of bed
you know ready to take on the day all
the way until the time where they they
go to bed and they don't need very much
sleep to function like five six hours
would you say that this is a trait that
you have I get eight hours of sleep a
day it seems like like you're you're
pretty energetic okay which is good it's
a good thing because it's a trait that
you can see what's it called hypo Mania
hypom Mania it's a trait that you can
see disproportionately in like the ultra
wealthy and successful people they're
very much go go go go go they're always
doing something when we were talking to
him he said he probably has hypomania as
well as his mother yeah yeah yeah I
don't I don't know I don't think I have
any
Manas I think I'm focused I think I have
intention you know I know I there's
certain targets I want to hit daily
weekly monthly and in my lifetime and
that's what I'm focused on so
unfortunately a lot of times you know
like that old stigma of work uh work
addiction or uh work
see we are a compulsive obsessive or
obsessive if you want a clean
environment you're OCD or something all
the things that would suggest something
POS overachiever is a problem yeah like
I want to be an overachiever I hope
she's an overachiever that'll be up to
her but I want to be I want a clean
environment I don't like stuff all over
the place I would never tolerate this
never that's that's Jack that was no
whatever whatever it's not it's
unacceptable you should take a shot of
it you know we will
show your audience what I'm looking at
pretty messy because because to me those
like there should be order so if I'm
hiring somebody I want to know am I
hiring the right person because the
interview is [__] but how do they
take care of their car how do they dress
when did they show up did they show up
on time when I ask them to hey man pass
my phone back to me do they say uh why
or they just pass the phone back see
that's a good guy you can duplicate an
order so there's just little tricks you
can do to hack who who is the person
across from you yeah I am curious before
before we wrap this up uh healthwise you
seem you're in incredible shape thank
you seem to be aging backwards how do
you how do you do this and you have zero
wrinkles on your forehead is another
thing BX no I do have wrinkles look at
my wrinkles no you don't I have more
wrinkles than you it has I have more
wrinkles than you yeah less than half
your age I don't think so man it has to
you 65 years of life on this face how do
you do it is it is it my my no one is my
face is very I have this face that can
handle a lot of beating up okay if you
see this scar right here yeah see that
you see these over the over the eyes
both those are scars right there you
can't see them why' you no I don't
really those are 76 stitches my my head
and face so my head my face is very
uh like that why did you need 76
stitches cuz I got I got pistol whipped
with a gun pistol whipped yeah when I
was 23 so someone hit you with the
somebody took the front of a 45 caliber
jammed it in in here right here okay
where your where your things go and and
jam that in there and then you see this
big raised bump on my head right here
and then cut over cut me with the back
of the gun on both my over both my eyes
and then my mouth how did he cut you
with the back of the pistol why were you
like constrained or something yes 100% I
was constrained really yeah how is it is
this inappropriate to talk about but I'm
very curious like how how did you get
put in this situation when when you hang
around with the wrong people so they
tied you up or something no they didn't
tie me up but they're holding you or
something yeah wow yeah so anyway but
that doesn't explain how do you that we
have more wrinkles than you do well I
don't I don't I don't think you have
more wrinkles than I I but that and they
and they stay a little bit now cuz I've
been thinking about doing B tongs yeah
cuz I don't like their wrinkles well do
whatever you got to do to feel good
about yourself just don't get beat up in
a process so that's what I would
recommend I stay away from that yeah
yeah so the other thing is 10x Health
like you walk you saw you see this Blue
Water right here we we uh no no you see
the blue yeah there was I noticed there
was a blue ttin to it I do everything I
can man what is that that I'm we're
working on this ingredient right now I
don't want to announce it yet because
I'm not ready but um we also don't want
to promote it just in case just just not
yet yet so I'm working on so you're the
guine pig so yeah we I bought a company
called uh streamline you might have seen
Gary Brea on it he'd be a good guy to be
on oh I would like to have him on yeah
and uh Gary was uh taking care of and me
uh maybe three or four years ago we
ended up buying this company and just we
just blew that company up he did he did
some stuff with Dana White a whole bunch
of celebrities that we're working with
now check out see how Steve Harvey's
doing Steve looks better than he's ever
looked so anyway we're using some
Alternative Healthcare to take care of
people and and uh I'm the first one that
jumps on that stuff and try it use it
see if it can stop or slow down aging
and uh but it's back to this thing about
man what can I do to feed the the
machine so that it operates how often
are you working out every day how do you
do that when you travel I didn't today
okay yeah that is impressive got to push
you guys around a little bit Yeah I need
it I've I mean I've been going but I
could certainly be better and this has
been my first Frappuccino thing in like
three four years so like I broke this
shoulder what February and they three
guys wanted to do surgery on it I said
no I'll fix it myself I'll I'll handle
it in the gym and uh now I'm back to
using it you know I could do this man I
couldn't do this for the first from
February till July I couldn't do that I
didn't have to put the screws or the
metal or the the bolts in my arm yeah
would you say you feel financially
secure do I feel F yeah of course yeah I
mean I can't spend the money I have it's
impossible I would have to be like I
don't think that I could I don't think
that I could get rid of it if I wanted
to so you feel in a it's more coming
from place of like abundance and
scarcity well there's still things I
can't do so that there there's a level
of scarcity because I can't there's some
things I can't do that I'd like to do MH
do you worry about the statistic that
after three generations most wealth has
gone away yeah and how do you prevent
something like that like what what
values will you instill I just worry
about the Next Generation like let me
get this one done let me my job's not
done and then I don't know that they're
even interested in the game if they're
not interested in the game they seems
like it they don't get the game
well she is today but today she says you
know but I don't who knows I mean who
knows any of this right so but it
doesn't mean they get it the person
that's going to be most qualified and
wants it the most is going to get
it they've had a good ride already yeah
I kind of want it so maybe I could throw
my name into that sure man you're a good
dude I like give it a shot
yeah uh is there anything else Jack I
think that's good yeah we don't want to
hold you guys to
apprciate thank you so much for coming
on thank you for coming on this
completely unexpected surpr surprise St
that was great you know what how about
this we'll end it on this any what what
are the values that you think all
parents should be instilling in their
children you know I would just say first
of all I don't want to give parental
advice to anybody because I know how
personal that
is I would tell you that pulling the
kids out of the school system has been I
will look back and say that was the best
thing we could do and everybody said oh
my God they're not going to be
socialized they're not going to know how
to talk to people oh they're going to
miss so much I'm like I hope so I wanted
to miss all that and so right now it's
working out good uh number two thing I
was tell you got to spend more time with
your kids and if they're at school all
day and you're at work all day and when
they come home you're tired you're not
spending really quality time with
them um so I would say that and and
then I mean what other advice would I
give kids uh parents parents you know
stop using drugs at home stop don't use
don't don't drink around your
kids um and be successful and take care
of yourself you can't if you're going to
feed them Cheerios and you're going to
eat Cheerios you guys are both going to
be obese we have the highest obesity on
planet Earth the highest obesity is one
of America's great products now obesity
the highest population of people that
are prescribe drugs live in this country
we consume more prescription medication
in this country than every other country
combined on planet Earth so we have the
fattest people we have the most uh the
most medicated people and we have a
society that has the most guns and I
believe in the guns I just don't believe
in the first two because the people with
the guns aren't going to be able to use
them because they're too fat to get to
their gun and or they're too medicated
to get to
it so that's my only advice you got any
advice CH any advice to parents kids
give the advice kids um let's see uh I
don't know you know be disciplined you
know it's like hard like you don't want
to go to school you just got to make
yourself do it sometimes like I've
learned a lot from having to have my
homeschool program and having to have
have to do it tonight and not be able to
put it off till tomorrow have to do this
have to do that have to have to uh you
know help out have to do blah blah blah
blah blah I've learned a lot from that
so be like be disciplined to make
yourself do stuff like I I think that
that will probably be when I'm like an
adult and stuff that will probably be
one of the greatest lessons I ever
learned so um just learn how to be
disciplined I think you should do more
than this popping on podcasts if your
dad is speaking on stage popping on and
popping off yeah on and popping off I I
speaking oh you do um yeah know I've
spoken to 34,000 people um when I was
when I was nine when I was 9 years old
um I spoke to was that at 10x event okay
I spoke to 10,000 people in manderlay
Bay and that speech um got I think I
think like 8 million views than any
video oh my gosh yeah so um I I I do
speaking publicly and it's a lot of fun
for me I really I really enjoy it like
it's like one of the one of the fun
factors in my life that's really cool
yeah that's awesome well thank you both
so much for your time really appreciate
it thank you for doing that appr yeah
thanks for hopping on thanks for let me
come on that was great we love it yeah
sorry to keep you a little later long
interviews
man